ils arrivent ici aux portes de la mort
l'unité de malnutrition de l'hôpital
mirwais à kandahar compte 32 lits plus
petits l'épousé massive ses patientes
le nombre d'admissions explose il faut
bien faire avec si le chef des soins
pédiatriques
toit de calme et de nous donner à bloc
en fait dans plusieurs délits se sont
souvent trois patients qui oscille entre
les pleurs et la difficulté à respirer
les jumeaux âgés a tenu sa et as raté sa
bataille pour survivre depuis trois
semaines
nous n'avons rien à manger à la maison
dit elle nous sommes pauvres il ma vie
ne sort plus travailler la doit d'abord
calé
d'argonne à leur mère dit qu'elle a
perdu neuf enfants dans le passé de quoi
sont ils morts elle n'en est pas
certaine ce qu'elle sait c'est que les
quatre ans quand toujours envie qu'elle
a laissée derrière pour venir depuis son
village ne vont pas beaucoup mieux alors
qu'on en a le droit des enfants sont
malades disent are gonna mais on n'a pas
les moyens de les soigner mode à la
location
unicef parle d'une urgence silencieuse
les problèmes de malnutrition ne sont
pas nouveaux en afghanistan mais les
derniers chiffres sont alarmants dit
l'organisme
[Applaudissements]
entre les mois d'août et décembre 2021
le nombre d'enfants admis pour
malnutrition dans les hôpitaux afghan a
doublé passant de 2407
le taux de dépérissement cet état de
malnutrition aiguë qui réduit ces
poupons à la peau et aux eaux s'élève
près de 10%
la pauvreté est une des grandes
responsables on estime que 97% des
afghans vivent aujourd'hui sous le seuil
de la pauvreté
mais selon le directeur des soins
pédiatriques ici l'ignorance est un
facteur aggravant pernicieux et le
traité ce tour aérien que madame de
l'eau
sans
picador
on peut difficilement croire que la
petite série ira à quatre ans c'est
pourtant ce qu'indique son dossier
médical c'est sa grand-mère qui l'année
pour être soigné à la maison sa mère
s'occupe de notre enfant et n'a que 12
ans je la grand mère
et comme si la crise n'était pas assez
sévères l'afghanistan ce moment fait
face à une sécheresse d'une ampleur
qu'elle n'a pas connue depuis près de
trois décennies
grosse
migraine et des séries a
estimé baek new morning 113 kg dj propos
migraines et des regards il craint de
perdre 70 % de ses revenus cette année
alors qu'au marché le prix augmentent
pour tous la farine l'huile et de
l'essence dont il a besoin pour faire
fonctionner la pompe qui lui permet
d'irriguer séchante déjà dit il il s'est
endetté pour payer le salaire de son
employé
nematullah craint des conséquences à
beaucoup plus long terme la terre
familiale et tout le travail de ses
ancêtres avant nuit pourrait être
anéantie
sentant de dur travail dit il pour avoir
un jardin tout donne de bons fruits les
ancêtres ont travaillé très fort pour
planter ces arbres et prendre soin de
cette date sous
barrots ces canaux d'irrigation sont
complètement sec depuis des mois il lui
reste un peu moins de deux semaines dit
il pour sauver ces arbres qui commence à
dessécher noir occupaient pour la soirée
il faut 10 jours pour que l'eau des
barrages arrive ici quand il est ouvert
dit il s'il barrage n'a pas assez d'eau
nous aurons beaucoup de problèmes nous
n'avons pas les moyens de creuser des
puits pour empêcher les arbres de
dépérir
quelques 20 mille hectares dans la
province de kandahar dépend du barrage
de dahla pour être irriguées mais ce
barrage construit dans les années 50 se
fait vieux en 2008 le canada débloquer
50 millions de dollars pour moderniser
le canal principal du barrage et 60
canaux secondaires le projet controversé
à l'époque devait être une vitrine de la
présence du canada à kandahar
abandonné en 2012 après des efforts
mitigé il n'est plus que le souvenir
d'une promesse non tenue pour les
agriculteurs ici
les fruits menace de tomber avant même
la maturité chez nematullah qui dit tout
voir en noir
nous avons peur de perdre notre jardin
dit il mais nous n'avons pas peur de
manquer de nourriture
allah a promis de donner à manger à
l'humanité
il semble pourtant tout aussi impuissant
que c'est mère désemparée à calmer les
cris de douleur incessants coups plus
vulnérables parmi les afghans se mariait
bédard radio-canada kandahar